[Music]
the edges of the cinematic classic
scarface
haven't softened over the years nor has
it grown
any less divisive here's the untold
truth
of one of the greatest bloodiest most
influential films of all time
the movie that came to largely defined
al pacino's career
likely would never have happened if he'd
just stayed home
instead of going out one night to watch
a movie
speaking with author lawrence grobel in
an interview that accompanied scarface's
blu-ray release
pacino said of the original 1932 film
i had heard about scarface for a long
time when i saw it
it had a real feeling to it a grand
feeling
and it had a great performance by paul
mewni he did something different
i thought it would be interesting to do
a remake of this so i called producer
marty bregman and he saw it and got very
excited
marty bregman originally wanted sydney
lumet
who directed pacino in dog day afternoon
to make the movie he also tried to get
oliver stone to write the screenplay
but stone wasn't interested in an
interview with creative screenwriting he
explained
i didn't like the original movie that
much and i had no desire to make another
italian gangster picture
because so many had been done so well
there would be no point to it
a brilliant idea by lumet to update the
film's setting changed stone's mind
pacino and bregman had both envisioned
the project as a period piece
more of a straight remake of the
original but lumet saw the story's
potential to translate well
to what was going on in florida at the
time turning it into
a modern retelling of the classic
immigrant gangster tale
first brought to the silver screen by
howard hawks
in 1932. stone said sydney had a great
idea to take the 1930s american
prohibition gangster movie
and make it into a modern immigrant
gangster movie dealing with the same
problems that we had then
that we're prohibiting drugs instead of
alcohol
he added that the cuban immigrants who
were deported to the united states in
1981
had quote gained a lot of publicity for
their open brazenness
at the time he said many felt that
cuba's leader
fidel castro was quote dumping all the
criminals into the american system
stone and bregman research the rocky
relationship between the cuban
immigrants
and the communities of southern florida
and stone also traveled to the caribbean
to document aspects of the drug trade
which he said was an interesting time he
said
there's no law down there they'll just
shoot you in your hotel room
it got hairy so
you got any money
to get his stuff in 2015
stone spoke with sabotage times about
his experience researching scarface
as it turned out while he was one of the
more qualified hollywood screenwriters
that marty bregman could have picked to
tackle the subject
he was also the last man who should be
diving headfirst into the drug trade
he said i was a cocaine addict for about
two and a half
years prior to writing scarface i knew
that world
the drug world of the early 80s very
well
when it came time to write a draft of
scarface stone decided to move to paris
where he knew that getting access to the
drug would be more difficult
speaking with empire the screenwriter
said
i was doing cocaine during the research
phase but then went
cold turkey during the writing in paris
i knew i couldn't break the habit in
florida
la or new york michelle
pfeiffer had been one of the biggest
movie stars in the world for so long
that it's easy to forget that there was
ever a time when she wasn't
but at the time bregman and brian de
palma who'd replaced the departed lumet
by this point
were casting scarface she had only
appeared in tv movies
guest roles in series like chips and
fantasy island
and a handful of minor features bregman
had his sights on her for the part of
elvira tony's drug-addled but
sharp-witted trophy wife
from the beginning but he was the only
one
pacino preferred glenn close while de
palma
and bregman auditioned a laundry list of
the hottest actresses in hollywood at
the time
among those to turn the part down were
kim basinger
melanie griffith and rosanna arquette
in the end pfeiffer won out and while
she may have been a relative unknown
her star power is obvious in the
do parts and you kill people oh that's
wonderful tony
real contribution to human history
scarface might have offered the
definitive portrait of the neon drug
choked streets of miami in the early 80s
but believe it or not the flick was only
partially shot on location
the city of miami wanted nothing to do
with the movie
as officials feared it would depict the
city as a haven for
organized crime and the drug trade the
crew
shot for only 12 days in miami mostly
exteriors and pickup shots
bregman moved the production to la for
the bulk of shooting
and many of the flicks most famous
scenes including the opening freedom
town riot
and the massive shootout at tony's
mansion at the film's end
were shot there one scene that was shot
in miami was the infamous chainsaw scene
in which tony's friend angel is murdered
in the bathroom of a seedy apartment
the shoot took place at an actual
apartment building on
ocean drive in miami one which regularly
attracts
throngs of film fans even today the
exterior of the building was even
preserved when it was converted to a cvs
in 2017. watch what happened to your
friend
you don't want this to happen to you
give me the money okay
it ended up being quite fortuitous for
at least one future filmmaker
that scarface was shot at least in part
in miami
in the background of the scene at the
pool the one in which tony gives manny
the iconic power speech
this country you gotta make the money
first
then when you get the money you get the
power a very young brett ratner can be
seen
ratner said in an interview with variety
in 2007
that he skipped school to watch them
shoot when he bumped into pacino years
later
he told pacino that it was because of
his inspiration that he became a
director
explaining why ratner said because i saw
you act
and i could never be that good so i
wanted to be the guy who told you what
to do
the final few minutes of scarface
feature one of the most epic gunfights
of all time
a scene that's so insane and bloody that
even hardcore fans could be forgiven
for not catching the sneakiest of all
cameos amid the chaos
that's because it happened not in front
of the camera but behind it
steven spielberg who just the year
before had fielded what was then the
highest grossing picture in history with
e.t the extraterrestrial
dropped by the scarface set during one
of the days the climax was being filmed
apparently just for grins de palma had
him direct
one single shot the one in which tony's
attackers first gained entrance to the
mansion
the infamous mansion scene is one of the
craziest movie climaxes
ever put to film and it's also notable
for another reason
while filming the gunfight pacino
tripped and accidentally grabbed the
barrel of a gun that had just been fired
around 30 times
injuring himself so badly it threatened
to shut down the entire shoot
pacino was taken to the nearby sherman
oaks burn center
the injury kept him out of action for
over a week and then there was even more
bad luck
while the production was picking up
scenes in his absence two stunt
performers were hurt when a bomb
prematurely exploded not many films have
ever been rated x for violence
but in the 80s several pictures came
close
and scarface was among them the mpaa
ratings board wasn't exactly taken with
the picture as a whole
but it was the bloody scene with the
chainsaw that caused them to initially
slap the film with an axe
after two rounds of cuts to the scene
the ratings board
still was unmoved and de palma
threatened to quit
rather than bring in a different
director to cut the film
universal pictures appealed the board's
decision
amazingly they won the appeal but then
de palma spoke up
the changes he had made from the
original cut were so slight he argued
that he should be able to restore them
and still get the r rating
the board disagreed and required him to
keep the cuts
but de palma got the last laugh in a
2013 interview with the talks the
director said
i was able to beat the ratings board
with scarface even though they raided at
x
i was able to appeal to the whole
committee and we got it passed
there's a lot of controversy about how
scarface was edited
but in reality everything i cut out to
appease the ratings board
i put back in and that's what you see
it may not shock you to know that upon
scarface's release
many critics were disgusted with the
movie in a review
people magazine was merciless the critic
wrote
characterization and plot go out the
window arms are cut off with chainsaws
the bloodbath that ends the film is an
insult to everything de palma has done
before
there is no style to this violence
everything seems to be in service
of an oscar stalking pacino performance
his acting
isn't acting it's shameless showing off
so is the movie
while the flick is obviously undergone a
critical reappraisal since then
that was fairly typical of reviews at
the time
the great roger ebert of course saw the
film for what it was
in his four-star review he wrote
scarface
understands the criminal personality
with its links between
laziness and ruthlessness grandiosity
and low self-esteem
pipe dreams and a chronic inability to
be happy
it's also an exciting crime picture in
the tradition of the 1932 movie
a wonderful portrait of a real laos
scarface is a film that is very much of
its time
and this is never more true than in the
infamous montage sequence that occurs
roughly midway through the picture
as tony builds his empire and begins
rolling in the dough
we're regaled with the insanely cheesy
disco-e strains of scarface
push it to the limit the song is pure
cheese and the sequence in which it
appears is so absurdly typical
of 80s montage sequences that it has
become something of an inside joke
it's been used to comedically score
similar montages in shows like
south park it's always sunny in
philadelphia an american dad
it's also been parodied countless times
going back to the scarface well
south park also took that route
employing an extremely similar
original tune that was actually called
montage in the episode
aspen so spot on is the song
that creators trey parker and matt stone
even used it again
in the 2004 feature film team america
world police
today scarface is considered to be a
classic
and one of de palma's best films but it
likely wouldn't enjoy this reputation if
not for a huge assist from the rap genre
rap artist immediately took to the film
it was released the same year as
grandmaster melly mel's white lines
a thematically similar work and it's
become inextricably linked with rap
sampled dozens of times and referenced
hundreds more
perhaps the earliest adopters were the
first incarnation of houston crew ghetto
boys
who extensively sampled dialogue from
the film on their 1988 debut album
making trouble
the trend would continue through the
name change and a massive shake-up in
the group's lineup
and one of the group's rappers even goes
by the moniker scarface
in particular the film's most iconic
line
has been firmly cemented in the public
consciousness
almost solely due to it having been
excessively sampled
it almost goes without saying that rap's
fascination with the movie has gone a
long way toward helping it remain in the
public consciousness
when scarface was released on dvd in
2003
it logged to be the most advanced orders
ever at the time
beating out the previous champ
spielberg's e.t
the extraterrestrial check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
popular films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one